today's question comes from Connie in
Connecticut they have a screwed up and a
co-signed a car loan for a relative at
now they aren't paying shocked and I'm
stuck would it be better to put it on a
zero interest credit your out card and
then pay it or try to refi it for a
better interest rate and pay it off it'd
be better to make them sell it and put
the balance on a zero interest credit
card because you're going to be in the
hole but they need to sell it today you
go pick the car up and get all in their
business and tell them sign the title
and you need to sell it and borrow the
money to cover the difference you've
lost your money but they've lost their
car this is why we never cosign
co-signing is stupid I've done it I had
people do it for me in every case
co-signing is stupid you're going to get
yourself in a mess debt is the most
aggressively marketed product in the
culture today and Connie's finding it
out the hard way believe me these people
at the bank these people at the finance
company they want to loan money more
than you want to borrow it and that's
hard to believe they want they are
aggressively selling their product
there are smarmy salesmen all up in your
business selling their product their
product is debt and if these aggressive
sales people selling their debt if even
they don't want to loan your relative
money believe me your relative is not
credit worthy because usually if your
relative could fog up a mirror they can
get a loan but if they're so bad they
can't get the loan and for God's sakes
you don't sign for them because a
hundred percent of the time you're gonna
have a problem 100 percent of time
because even if they pay it exactly on
time it limits your ability to do things
in your life it's called contingent
liability in the accounting systems
never
cosin it's stupid says it in the Bible
proverbs 1718 contemporary English
version CEV look it up here's what it
says one who cosines for another is
stupid
says it in the Bible it's exactly what
it says you don't like that version okay
you could look it up in the New King
James it says one lacking in sin son
surety for another pretty much the same
thing you're stupid if you cosign when I
cosign you know what I was stupid when
somebody cosign for me you know what
they were stupid co-signing stupid hope
I haven't been unclear so if your little
grandson wants to buy a little truck and
your little grandson hadn't got any
money and you co-signed for your little
grandson you're stupid if your kids want
to buy a house and they don't have the
money and you cosign form you're stupid
if your sister is sick and has to have a
car to get to the hospital and you
cosign for you're stupid you're going to
pay the bill if you don't have the money
to write the check and buy the thing and
give it to them
you don't have the money to cosign I've
been stupid Connie has been stupid some
of you have been stupid and every time
I'm stupid you know what it cost me
money when it costs me money and I'm
stupid I call it stupid tax I have paid
so much stupid tax in my life I want to
pay it more than once trying to pay the
same bill more than one time so just
some of you that are out there and you
still you're still sweet and young and
innocent and stupid and you think you
can cosign and somebody's going to pay
it oh he's my brother he'll keep his
word you're stupid
your brother's going to lose his job and
he meant to keep his word but he
couldn't get a job and then he didn't
sign he didn't pay that five hundred
sixty dollar truck payment on this
behemoth of a truck that he didn't need
to start with the prove his manhood
please it was stupid don't buy the truck
have I hit any of your home yet and
think of all the possible reasons your
sister does not need a new couch
that's stupid pay cash for it all these
little reasons little Johnny sweet
little Johnny's a good guy little johnny
is a good boy that's great but if you
cosign for
you're stupid never cosign it's stupid
gosh I hope I haven't been unclear I'm
just trying to keep you away from the
pain folk Connie's feeling the pain
she's feeling the pain of stupid stupid
I'll hit you in the back of the head and
say stupid it'll tell you you're stupid
I've done it oh man it hurts oh it hurts
a double bad because you got to write
the check and then you got look at
yourself in the mirror and go you were
stupid I've done that I don't want to do
it again I don't want you to do it again
don't cosign ever for anyone for
anything under any circumstances there
is no possible explanation for you
co-signing on the planet if you do not
have the money to buy it and give it to
them you do not have the money to
co-sign it is a straight-up freaking
liability and they will make you pay
because they knew from the first day
they being the bank that you were going
to pay because they knew little Johnny
wasn't credit worthy it's no shock to
them that you end up paying it but we're
all aghast
I can't believe Josie didn't pay Josie's
always been a good little girl I can't
believe they let me down now I'm losing
my home no you're the only one that
doesn't believe it the rest of us knew
it the bank knew it I knew it
deep down little Josie knew it buying
crap you can't afford really really
really can't afford when you need a
cosigner listen if you love your family
don't ask them to co-sign for you if you
like your friends don't ask them to
co-sign for you because they're just
gonna look at you and say no listen Dave
Ramsey he said that's stupid the reason
I say that is because it's stupid hey
you guys Rachel Cruise here hope you're
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right kind of
same room to channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you